amo allora cosa facciamo domani sera ma
come che giornale è capodanno capodanno
aspettativa verso se realtà
iscriviti al canale per non perdere
neanche un video una festa in casa a
capodanno
no non ci siamo proprio io avevo pensato
a qualcosa di molto di top un party
esclusivo su alcune cose lì asse
trattivo che è arrivato messaggio detto
fatto
ci hanno appena invitato il parte del
mondo preparati rehn tunisini piano open
bar e special guest sean mendes michele
morrone kayaba senza frigo alzate voglio
dire non credo ci sia molto da
organizzare c'è un capodanno in casa
facciamo che ti aiuto io il countdown lo
facciamo in salone ok sul divano
apriamo la bottiglia e ci bagniamo le
labbra buon anno a ci alziamo andiamo in
balcone salutiamo i vicini facciamo gli
auguri a loro dopo di che andiamo in
camera e finiamo quest'anno di merda
dormendo ok allora questo pazzesco cioè
lo amo tantissimo però se proprio devo
trovare una pecca ecco queste manichini
un po mi invecchiano troppo anni 80
cambiamo questo lo adoro supersexy però
è rosso e poi forse un po troppo
spagnoleggiante no direi che non è
adatto a capodanno e lui l'ho trovato e
pazzesco comodo così potrà ballare tutta
la notte fino alle 7 del mattino ma allo
stesso tempo sexy senza essere volgare
bello è bello cioè mi è sempre piaciuto
però c'è un pò natalizie troppo
natalizio il natale finito qualcosa di
un po più neutro carino però boh tutto
questo se questo scritto così evidente
perché guardando bene
qua mi fa anche un po difetto non vorrei
che in videochiamata si vedesse perfetto
cioè abbiamo trovato l'auto per questo
capodanno comodo caldo ma anche con un
tocco di magic e di piede sco che non
guasta mai
questa festa guarda mi sta guardando
guarda quanta come stimola comprati e
tanto chiama sicura la strada che porta
la vita per dire i bagni formali e
leviosa non leviosa libia guardarmi il
titanic a capo
jack ma c'è posto c'è posto sposto la
net.it anche tu salvati tavolo guarda
che veste diversa più mi dia contro dai
notare ma soprattutto tesi di farseschi
dice europeo valore lo show man è troppo
buono
ciao amo che stai preparando la tisana
tu io lo sto già vivendo mamma ti girano
so più che cosa guardare ho finito il
catalogo netflix pensare che l'anno
scorso eravamo al party dell'anno con
tutti più buoni della città dai tempi ma
torneranno speriamo se non rimango si
della vita potevo di certo che questa
storia dell'open bar di verdini
20 10 10 venire solo mai subito a
prenderne un altro io sono al 22esimo è
anche voi dobbiamo essere bari ok allora
all'olfatto sento la predominanza del
biancospino e della passiflora ma c'è
anche quella punta di agrumato non vedo
l'ora di assaggiarla paradisiaca vabbè
ma la amo ci voglio subito andare a
prendere un'altra ed ero piccolo io vivo
bene e dopo finita allo ster a casa mia
perché quest'anno ben 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 2 a
buonanno buonanno mamma o buonanno papa
finisco latisana e vengo dormire anche
io è il meno male che ce la siamo tolti
dalle palle buon anno anche voi mariners
commentate qui sotto iscrivetevi al
canale
[Musica]